das ist Q&A zur Reportage Freeriden
tödliches Risiko für den ultimativen
Adrenalinkick mehr zugeschaltet ist der
sameprotagonist Reportage fließig
schreibt zum Beispiel krank
Feedbacks wird aus von Justin Nerd freut
uns natürlich besonders wenn es
irgendwie gelungen ist wie sie Passion
transportieren und auch eine aufzeigen
dass man nicht einfach völlig kopflos
wie es irgendwie time abstürzt es sind
aber auch gute Fragen und da merke ich
Ihnen
schreibt zum Beispiel superreportagen
ja Messi für die Frage ich glaube das
ist sehr gute Frage also immer mehr leid
immer mehr Unfall das ist zum Glück
nicht so also wenn ich oft waldbekomme
momentan 2019
[Musik]
126 Unfall
203 Personen wo erfasst wurde sind und
nur 15 Personen sind und das ist
sicherer dadurch dass die
litwenabschnittagenten
Material mit und gehen mit Kopf in die
Berge wahrscheinlich schön Entwicklung
respektiere und und nicht einfach ja
kopflos in die bergarbeit und da
beschissen
sehr guter Beitrag gute Reflexionen den
youtube-titel finde ich jedoch etwas
überrissen
also wirklich das ist eigentlich
Feedback an Dich Matthias total der
Nabel von Meeres gesehen der Youtube
Titel also
Schlagwörter und alles aber ich finde
schlussendlich ähm hätte hätte das mit
dem Adrenalin und Todes lusten all Danz
gar nicht gar nichts mehr was wir da
gemacht also für mich der Titel gesehen
würde ich jetzt jeder Tag im Tod face to
face also wirklich geil genug und so ist
das nicht also aber zwei Sachen dürfen
wir festhalten
für irgendwie
Feeling nennen wir jetzt das
adrenalinkrecht
nicht wirklich ehrlich sind mit dem was
passiert ist oder hat könnte passieren
sehr emotionale Frage also klar wenn
Kollegen
aber wiederum der Schnitt mit dem
Bergsport durch Fähre wir Reihe ich
Kollege verloren und ich haben sie mal
Kletterer
und schlussendlich
aber direkt der beste
und für mich bringt einfach
in der bergsportiert
[Musik]
gefährlich ich liebe deine das das ist
für mich keine Option aber sicher der
zweite Teil von der Frage eigentlich
Ehrlichkeit also wenn etwas passiert das
sind wir vielfach als manche da und die
das Ganze also mit Suizid der Schere
also
aber da muss es passiert wir versuchen
weil er Fehler dass die Personen eine
Berge gemacht oder wenn man Lawine
Umfallen
das eigene sehr schnell einmal ja die
Sonne Box und emotional auf Zitation
sagen okay das passiert mir nicht aber
das habe ich jedem passieren
das müssen meine realisieren und aber
ehrlich gesagt
der alex schrieb hattest du die Abfahrt
bei guten Bedingungen wirklich gemacht
das Risiko wäre doch auch so
verhältnismäßig zu hoch also ich glaube
in frage mich weil das sieht gemacht hat
dass ich Diskussions
können fahren
ist dementsprechend
hatte das heißt richtig
einfacher zum Fahren das Balancieren
guten Tag wie oft muss sehen eigentlich
seine Ausrüstung Ski und Skistöcke
erneuern
je nachdem auf der Winter wie viele
Steine hat es mir nicht bekommen Stärke
die Kanäle
zwischen
Jahr genau wenn wenn neue Saison beginnt
also nächsten november
und fahre die sozusagen jetzt end
bestehen immer wirklich funktionieren
und dann nehmen der neue Ski wenn wir
wieder mehr Schnee hat
vernünftig mit der
Fragen
und würde mal so schätze an die so 40
bis 45 sind und normalerweise
150 gesagt
wie soll man Hilfe holen wenn es öfter
keinen Handyempfang gibt in den Bergen
und sehr gute Frage wird am Profi mit
fünf Erfahrungen also wir haben vielfach
in den Bergen aus garminister
sogar da ähm also wäre das nicht nur in
der Schweiz mit sondern auf Expeditionen
Alaska in Pakistan
ganz einfach das kann man verbinden mit
dem Handy und der Schweiz
das funktioniert über GPS also wenn es
okay Handyempfang geht genau zum zum
verstaut
und schlussendlich ohne Hände Empfang
ist es wirklich erreichbar vor ja
überall auf der Welt
vom wildes Pony 92
wie funktioniert die Rettungskette oder
die Rettung allgemein bei entlegenen
Expeditionen wie zum Beispiel in
Pakistan in der Schweiz ist ja je nach
Wetterlage eine Rettung extrem schnell
möglich jedoch in größeren und stelle
ich mir das schon etwas komplizierter
vor
ja gut also ich erfahre ich meine
Erfahrung Zermatt ich bin
und das war während der Schweiz ist
absolut
technisch Level also technischer
150 Meter abgestürzt und wer einen
rettignisse organisieren und Rettungs
einfach
da ist also ist Team hätten funktioniert
das ist ja Kollege vom Berg kommt und
schlussendlich und die da kein
Helikopter keine
regenposition sind aber dass das
überhaupt nicht irgendwie Standarte
erwartet rund um die Welt oder
es grundlegendes Problem wo wir in der
Schweiz dass wir einfach
das Backup und wechselt mehr und mehr
das würde Giger rette hier in der
Schweiz und es sind Wanderer wo einfach
erschöpft sind
und klar werden
Reportage wenn du weiterhin
abonniert jetzt der Kanal es lohnt sich
sehr